it never occurred to me for a second
that I should write a risk assessment
called don't blow up a [__] star
I take my job quite seriously
I write or lots and lots of risk
assessments and they're detailed they're
long
nobody reads them the main thing in my
risk assessment it says alien technology
you don't play with it
in the last 12 months alone
and this is mostly sg1
led by O'Neill with two L's still tells
me that every single time they have
ended up using alien technology that
made them superhumans
that went badly because it then just
stopped working at the worst possible
moment
after they basically became
complete Pricks for like three days it
was like they were drug addicts
they decided to fly an experimental
aircraft without I would argue enough
safety checks literally the first time
O'Neill
two L's and uh tealc flew it
they nearly died
we had to get help from the tokra Sams
bad not bad I had to come and save them
but you know to me
I don't get me wrong you know we have to
experiment with this stuff and we have
to practice but you know put some safety
measures in any really just just a
couple
check for Alien Devices that you know
commandeer the vessel and send it back
home
[Music]
I
I genuinely this team couldn't do much
more than it's done to make my life a
misery
they couldn't there's there's not a lot
really O'Neill who else tioc Sam Carter
or Daniel Jackson could actually do
to make my life harder they caught us in
a Time Loop
they went to an alien world p4x639
they again didn't run
when they're told to scissors Got Run
don't walk any technology somewhat weird
run away
they didn't
they engaged they messed around and they
got caught in a Time Loop now to be fair
it was teal and O'Neill that really
suffered with this one but if they
hadn't have solved that
we'd be stuck in that time Loop forever
blissfully unaware that basically we
were as good as dead
how do you write a risk assessment for
that
how do I do risk assessment for
Groundhog Day
Groundhog Day the risk assessment
what
I don't even know where to start with
that I mean it's just it's just
but I think this is the limit I don't
think they could do anything else to
make my life any more difficult than
that at least
the Russians they have been using the
Stargate and they went to a world that
basically had water life
the water was alive basically they
kidnapped some of those water
life forms
they invaded the bodies of the Russians
and you know name
mayborn was involved in that
he's nearly as bad as O'Neill two l's
but you know it's it's it's it's it was
okay in the end
but then we sent a probe and we got
invaded by electronic life forms
one of them actually
took over
Captain Samantha Carter
I no don't get me wrong I don't know how
the science of that works
they basically separated their
Consciousness from her brain I I don't
know how the science of that works
but it did
and again I now have to figure out a way
of preventing from that happening again
if that's the worst thing Captain Carter
does this year then
that's fine because I said they
they're really making my life very hard
she blew up a [__] star
she took a Stargate
connected to a black hole that's
something I forgot to mention apparently
you can connect Stargates to black holes
they threw that Stargate into a star
and um
defeated a major goal walled attack
threat enemy blur in the process but
Superstar
had
blood
I tell them
don't mess with alien technology
they do all the time
stick the redness sometimes
I tell them
if so much weird run away from it
because we keep getting
just just
we come back close to being dead like
all the time like every week
it's like once a week something really
bad happens
I tell them
it never occurred to me for a second
that I should write a risk assessment
called don't blow up a [__] star
what
she has no idea
what harm that could have caused
did we survey all the planets and make
sure there's no life no
quick look
we caused a supernova they're massive
did we check that the star system next
to it
doesn't have life because that radiation
in energy wave is going to affect more
than just that solar system
didn't you
seemed like a good idea at the time
how do I
seriously
I did keep doing these reports and I
send them out there and a nobody is
watching these reports nobody
if you're watching these reports I'd be
fired by now
but you know I'm not
I haven't even had a response
I resigned a month ago
nobody seems to care
I just gotta let it back basically
saying no
it's not because I'm good at my job
[__] because I'm the only idea that'll
do it
and I might have signed
stuff to say I can't ever leave
seemed like a good idea at the time
she blew up a star
[Music]
thank you